Після вторгнення в Україну хакерська група Анонімус оголосила війну Росії.
Анонімус стверджує, що вони зламали базу даних Міністерства оборони Росії і навіть Російського ядерного інституту.
Яку роль у цій війні відіграє найвідоміше у світі хакерське угруповання? І чи можуть Анонімус зламати системи, які відповідають за ядерну зброю?
Анонімус - це хакерське угруповання, створене неформально та децентралізовано.
Тому неможливо встановити, хто за які атаки відповідальний. Але після оголошення війни, хакери, пов’язані з Анонімус, заявили наступне:
Російське державне телебачення нібито було атаковане, щоб показати кадри війни.
А з бази даних міноборони Росії оприлюднили таємні документи.
Інший хакер, пов’язаний з Анонімусом, стверджує, що російські урядові сайти, інформаційні агенції та банки також зазнали хакерських атак.
Загалом буцімто понад 1500 російських сайтів були паралізовані протягом 72 годин.
За даними Анонімуса, вони зламали сторінку російського Інституту ядерних досліджень і викрали понад 40 000 документів.
Анонімус має досвід проведення ідеологічно мотивованих операцій, пов’язаних із актуальними новинами.
Ми бачили, що останні були спрямовані на російські ЗМІ.
Ми також читали повідомлення, що вони націлилися на телевізійні станції, мережі руху потягів тощо.
Але, стверджуючи таке, ми маємо бути обережними, оскільки є велика кількість таких заяв,
і може бути дуже складно верифікувати їх, що підвищує ймовірність поширення дезінформації.
У минулому хакери Анонімус вже завдавали клопоту багатьом великим гравцям: ЦРУ, терористам "Ісламської держави" і релігійній секті саєнтологів.
Через його неформальну організацію, важко чітко зрозуміти стратегію і цінності, які відстоюють хакери.
Теоретично будь-хто може діяти під іменем Анонімус. Приміром, німецький підрозділ Анонімус пояснив свої атаки на Росію так:
"Це не операція проти народу Росії. Навіть російські солдати не є ціллю. Це операція проти Путіна і підконтрольного йому державного апарату".
За словами угрупування, головна ціль - захистити Україну та її інфраструктуру від кібератак з боку Росії,
а також значно додати роботи російським айтішникам, аби "вони не могли завдати жодної шкоди Україні чи Заходу".
Коли ми бачимо такі атаки на кшталт відмови в обслуговуванні, коли мережі переповнені трафіком, то сама атака відносно проста у проведенні.
Це не особливо витончено. Але я думаю, що вся ідея цих операцій не повинна бути технічно складною.
Не потрібно навіть викликати технічні збої. Насправді наслідки більшою мірою є психологічного та символічного характеру.
Гадаю, що зараз, як ніколи, дуже важливо створити своєрідний наратив, щоб мати можливість впливати на наратив у ЗМІ.
Те, що робить Анонімус, це намагання перешкодити спробам Росії зробити це прямо зараз.
У соцмережах дії хакерів проти Росії зустрічають бурхливими оплесками.
Деякі користувачі навіть закликають угруповання зламати російську військову ядерну програму, щоб запобігти атомній війні.
Гадаю, вкрай малоймовірно, що це переросте у щось із справді реальним ефектом.
Якщо ми візьмемо до прикладу ядерні системи, то там величезна система безпеки з контролю
за всіма процесами і функціонуванням усього, що має відношення до ядерних технологій.
Принаймні з допису в блозі німецького Анонімусу випливає, що націлюватися на російську інфраструктуру, здається, для них - не варіант.
"Анонімус можуть використовувати різкі слова, але вони завжди свідомі того, що це небезпечна ситуація.
Активісти знають, що атака на критичну інфраструктуру, таку як атомні електростанції
чи системи контролю транспортного руху, - це те, що ми не чіпаємо".
Отже, хакери Анонімус не вважають себе частиною цифрової війни з фізичними атаками.
Схоже, вони воліють, щоб їх розглядали як активістів, які грають на нервах Росії за допомогою цифрових засобів.